how about that dinner we went to with
homeboy oh man you
brian would have said something he's not
as nice he would have said something
i don't know i don't know him really
yeah so
uh
well i can say his name so leister who
loves monster by the way he's the best
if you ever get a fight call that guy
but uh
leester who i talked to damn there every
week like we still do you still every
week all the time all the time all the
[ __ ] time
but he goes i'm gonna never get i don't
get the schedule so he's like hey this
guy that i know is a big fan he wants to
take you to dinner and we're like okay
cool so it's klopp austin you know
jay chappelle and me and then lisa two
of his wrestling buddies one was like
all-american oklahoma state and the
other i forget maybe oklahoma monsters
tough guys yeah he was some guys
all-american as a freshman first time
you've ever seen klopp
no second time but every time i see him
i'm like you ever seen him with a shirt
off no he
you know the incredibles you know that
tv show yeah the incredibles that
cartoon that's exactly what it is he
shred it up oh he's huge oh no no dude
no no
no six five
uh has the worst diet in the world
eats doughnuts
i'm talking about a six-pack i'm talking
about a six-pack uh the craziest
physicality there you go
that's what he looks like and he's he
just lifts some weights not a lot he
doesn't really lift anymore no look at
him he's on the beach
his legs and ass he's built like
superman let's zoom in on him for a
second
oh that's better yeah
that that's him
eating hamburgers and [ __ ] nothing he's
like that right now he's
but look at his legs his legs and ass
are a whole different thing he's a beast
so he's so he's at the dinner austin's
at dinner jay
and uh i'm sitting in front of lisa
chappelle's right next to me and then
the wrestler's next to chappelle and the
other rest is over there and then lisa's
friends over there
and he's ordering martinez he's loud
he's loud and he's wearing like you know
he's older guy but he's very very
wealthy very very wealthy so you know he
is an ego he's one in life
yeah in his mind yep big time in
whatever neighborhood he's in and so he
comes and he's sitting down he is uh uh
like a robert graham slash [ __ ]
um
it was like it was like a button-up
collared shirt yeah it was black with
skulls all over it and had the matching
skull hat i'm like we'll definitely
don't wear that but so he's like but
he's loud and he's ordering martinis i'm
like okay but he's getting louder
because he was ordering a lot of those
martinis and he's with a bunch of big
strong guys yeah he's safe so you got a
big wall his waitress is there you know
waitress and that one the nicest
steakhouse grayson something in uh
denver great steakhouse garden grace
garden garden grace great [ __ ]
restaurant so the waitress there you
know it's a
cocktail waitress you know sometimes
they have their titties up you know they
get so she has her tits up in a push-up
bra and big-sized tits
nice looking lady you know
it's a nice restaurant she's dressed
classy there's nothing it's not hooters
she's your waitress
she's uh bringing drinks
so he needs another drink
he goes
mill the restaurant stands up yells
muffin top
muffin top and i'm like this who
was he have tourettes i do dude are you
in the 50s dude
no in a time machine dude it was like
going to
dinner with clint eastwood in 1960 yeah
then he goes come here sister he was
coming sister or as a drink and he was
muffin top and i thought he saw there's
a heavier set waitress i thought muffin
top to me means i went spilling over the
juice right but he was referenced for
basically yes he was so she so she she i
guess find it kind of cute like bringing
another drink she's walking away slaps
her ass
no
and i i that's assault i go what in the
[ __ ] yeah so i text least her because he
can hear me i go dude this guy's the
liability here's the problem is if he
can if he gets worse can he do this the
the news isn't going to be you got to go
oh leester bowling this random guy rich
with a terrible shirt on and slap him
girl's asses it's going to be brendan
schaub's group of friends that's right i
was like this is a liability i can't be
part of it dude so the food comes you've
never seen a human being eat an eight
ounce filet faster in his life i lured
two bites
i gotta get the [ __ ] out of here so i
lied make up a story that aft it was
like three hours before the show i'm
like yeah they actually mean for a sound
test so i mean chappelle and jared
wouldn't get going and so uh he's like
wait wait wait wait wait and he's like
in this side
you know
because he's drunk and he was hey man i
want to be a stand-up comic when i was
younger i'm like oh [ __ ] he's like you
give me hope he goes you give me help
and i go oh thank you that i find that
all right vaguely insulting yeah yeah
all right yeah so then uh he goes yeah
mom dudes now you're well there's open
mics in denver man i can get you a list
whatever you want to do and he goes yeah
man and in my head i'm like oh he's
gonna be he's gonna be annoying during
the show because i come in the shop
so i text chappelle david right and uh
klopp yeah and diego this guy i'm
telling you this guy's gonna be a
problem we gotta keep our eye on him and
i text lisa hey lisa i know this guy you
know i've seen this type of personality
before i promise you he's gonna be loud
at the show it's gonna be an issue at
least she goes no he's good man boy i go
i i'm telling you now dude the guy who
goes there's a host then there's two
features than me the guy who goes on
second his name is david lucas and he's
a professional roaster he's gonna wait
it's literally he doesn't he competes in
roast battles yeah he's a
professional he'll go on ig live and
just raise fans and like destroy and
just like
so whenever whatever city we're in we
owe during his that not mine travels
during his set we hope somebody heckles
them we'll come out the green room
because he's made people cry yeah he
shut the show down he's he says he sets
the tone like no one else talks about
he's destroyed because he'll go you want
to keep talking i get two more coming
they can do the same thing so they pipe
down he lights people up
so
show starts i see i know where they're
seeing there's five empty chairs i'm
like man i wonder where that middle
david set they're gonna sit down
and here it is there's a
miscommunication i didn't know the
miscommunication i thought he was trying
to heckle david and i warned leister so
that guy goes sitting next to easter and
lisa goes no dude you're fat ass go down
go scoot two over put uh whatever jerry
here he's skinnier
and he responds loud and goes i'm not a
fat ass well david's on stage and just
hears fat ass and david is a big boy boy
so dave goes what the [ __ ] you just call
me and we're all fight like this
oh no
he goes what the [ __ ] just called me and
he's like knocked fat ass but he always
hears his fattest skin he was i'm a fat
ass
dude
that's not what i was talking about yeah
he goes who the [ __ ] let you out of the
house dressed like that my man he into
there's black skulls over it he goes you
look like the shower curtain from
beetlejuice he goes hey he goes i bet if
he goes he goes i bet if you say uh
beetlejuice three times a gay dude jumps
on your back
and then just kept
it just like light lightning the shirts
on buttoning is american flagstring is
that american flag shirt he goes i know
sure as [ __ ] you got a fake vaccination
card up in this [ __ ] and dude 10
minutes just
fighting this dude his face is just red
dead just red crushed him i text lisa
because i didn't know it's a
miscommunication i'm telling you dude if
he talks during chappelle's set i'm
working they're going to kick him out
security went to him and he was like oh
it's a miscommunication but i didn't
hear any of that so it takes lisa i'm
like i'm telling you dude if he keeps
talking they're going to kick him the
[ __ ] out i didn't know it was a
miscommunication none of
them
this guy has my whole body tight
like i feel tight but he got jealous but
he got like the hell yeah
yeah but like he's just he's just one of
those wealthy dudes that's just like
you see it all the time you know what
i'm talking about
yeah dude are you from the 1950s yeah a
man
of a certain age who's made a lot of
money hasn't had anybody tell them to
shut them there's an e yeah there's an
ego you know khabib was talking about
that with a certain fighter who's very
famous uh and uh we all know connor yeah
and he said the guy got so famous that
the problem is that sometimes i don't
know if that's the case with conor but
this was something he said that you
could apply to other things he said you
get really famous and people stop
telling you the truth you made a certain
amount of money where
you need people who keep you honest yeah
bro he slapped the table and said come
here sister no no it's like no just
straight up just muffins
and then slapped her ass when she when
he stopped i was like i need to go now
yeah that's like i can't be part of this
you got to run away yeah we got out real
quick
damn we should probably go like
more mashed potatoes like nah man
yeah that's a problem
the mashed potatoes were good though
what the [ __ ] is